hey youtubers is Charlie since Gotham is
premiering next week I wanted to do a
non-spoilery review and explain how the
show fits into the canon you know who
some of the big characters are and what
to look forward to in season one so
important stuff first episode 1 airs
Monday September 22nd at 8 p.m. Eastern
Time on Fox that's in the United States
in the UK it's on channel 5 so for other
international countries just check your
local listings I will be doing videos
for all four of the DC TV shows during
the week obviously Gotham is just
premiering first the other shows are the
flash arrow and constatine so be sure to
subscribe to get my videos it's gonna be
fun season and I'm probably gonna be
giving away some swag for each of the
shows so just to give you guys some
setup for Gotham if you haven't been
watching my videos so far the show is
told from detective Gordon's perspective
played by Ben McKenzie it has all the
DNA of the Batman universe from the
comics without looking like it's trying
to straight-up copy the Gotham from the
Christopher Nolan movies the thing about
the Christopher Nolan movies that were
that they treated the Batman mythos as
if it were happening in modern-day with
real people no whack EU superpowers or
anything like that Gotham the TV series
is a little bit more open to the idea
that even though it's not going like
straight to Justice League like arrow in
the flash are initially what we're
starting out with is James Gordon on his
first year of the force I felt like it
had a lot in common with the story of
Batman year one if you ever watch the
movie or read the comic so Ben McKenzie
does have experience playing a police
officer I never watched him on Southland
but when I was watching the episode it
was a little bit like training day like
I was thinking this is training day and
he's like the Ethan Hawke character
obviously that makes Donal Logue playing
Bullock the Denzel character I'm only
using that reference to talk about their
relationship and where Gordon's
character fits in with the rest of the
police force Donal Logue as detective
Bullock is like the other big shining
star of the series
it's like those two guys like there's
like the big stars if you've ever seen
him play any other character on any
other show you totally get why he's
perfect for Bullock it's not a copy of
Bullock from Batman the Animated Series
he's not that sleazy but he's close like
he's very jaded if you were to talk
about his alignment I would still think
of him as being like true neutral you
know he's not like the quarterback the
gym Gordon is trying to be but he's also
not a total dirtbag so then we have to
talk about the city itself Gotham City
it's his
character as anyone else I feel like
that's something that the comics
portrays really well you know Gotham as
a character so I feel like any good TV
series or movie also has to do that one
of the more fun things about the pilot
is how it sets up the city's character
arc visually it takes a lot from Ridley
Scott's Blade Runner the difference is
that in that movie it was Los Angeles of
the future in Gotham has always been a
bit of an analogue for New York City but
just like Blade Runner you get the sense
that the city is slowly dying there's
this belief that matter only has two
states of existence growth and decay and
you get the sense that Gotham is very
much in a sense of decay like when we
see Gotham City it is just slowly
starting to die of course the
implication being that over the course
of the series the city is gonna turn
into this chaos vacuum that just eats
light and goodness and that's basically
where Batman steps in puts on the cowl
and fills the vacuum just to give you an
idea of what the timeline is for the
show when we meet Bruce Wayne in Episode
one he's essentially eight years out
from putting the cowl on he's basically
pre high-school age like he's not in
high school yet in quick sidenote
there's actually a batman comic set in
gotham city with high school kids it's
called Gotham Academy so I recommend you
check that out on comiXology it's
actually pretty fun so moving along the
rogues gallery of villains that we're
gonna be at least you know initially is
led by Jada Pinkett Smith and Robin Lord
Taylor she's playing fish Mooney he's
playing Oswald Cobblepot if you're a
Walking Dead fan you might remember
Robin Lord Taylor from Walking Dead
Season four he played the Sam that that
guy that Rick and Carol almost killed
Jada pinkett-smith was interesting as
like this big crime boss villain I never
really seen her play someone like that
she's got 16 episodes to develop her
character which is you know way more
time than the crime bosses from the
Christopher Nolan movies so I think
it'll be pretty interesting the majority
of the first episode focuses on Oswald
Cobblepot though which actually made me
really happy that the paint was one of
my favorite Batman villains and his
character arc is a lot like the city
itself on the show
Gotham slowly descends into madness and
Cobblepot also slowly descends into
madness at the same time until he
eventually takes on the penguin persona
they actually just revealed that Carol
Kane is playing his mother they released
this promo image so you can kind of see
you know why he might be a little bit
crazy
I was actually really happy when they
cast her I feel like she's perfect for
the Penguins mother they've also
announced they're bringing Hugo Strange
on and they're going to be developing
Arkham Asylum as a big location Gotham
is a Batman origin story and it's also
going to be an Arkham Asylum origin
story which is really exciting Arkham is
gonna be like the mystery briefcase of
pain that the writers reach in do to
pull out Batman villains each week if
you've never heard the briefcase of pain
story it's something from Joss Whedon he
said that he was talking to Anthony
Hopkins on the set of Thor of the dark
world and he gave him this really crazy
story about where he finds his
motivation Hawkins just explained that
he keeps this tiny mental briefcase
where he stores painful things and
whenever he needs a character to be
really crazy or go out on a big limb he
just reaches into the briefcase and
pulls out something so Arkham Asylum is
gonna be Gotham's tiny briefcase of pain
I also just like the idea of Anthony
Hopkins just walking around with a tiny
little briefcase so the other big
villains we see in the pilot include the
Riddler Catwoman and poison ivy
obviously before they became those
personas the show treats them in this
very Precog way you know what their
future is and it's the job of the series
to show you how it all unfolds the
Riddler's actually one of the biggest
characters that I'm looking forward to
seeing more of he doesn't have a big
part in the premiere but his role in the
show like his job on the show puts him
right next to Gordon and Bullock and so
on the other side of the fence we have
young Bruce Wayne and Alfred the premier
doesn't focus on that too much it
basically just sets up all the triggers
for what's going to be happening to them
over the season David Mizzou's who plays
a young Bruce Wayne does a really good
job I'm interested to see how often the
show visits his character he's not the
main character of the series but he is
one of the most important ones he's a
little kid so you know he might be short
but he cast a very long shadow I
actually found myself looking for Batman
Easter eggs and some of the shadows
whenever he was in scenes Alfred is
played by Sean Pertwee from the
Musketeers if you watched any might
Doctor Who videos you'll also know him
as the son of the third doctor so just a
fun Doctor Who Easter egg his version of
Alfred plays a little bit more on his
history in the British military Pertwee
is like a much bigger person so his
Alfred is much more of a fighter than
like the Gandalf version played by
Michael Caine I'm really looking forward
to like some big Alfred fistfights or
teaching Bruce Wayne how to defend
self against bullies the other young
members of the cast Catwoman and poison
ivy are also only briefly seen in the
episode but it's just because of the
time limitations we'll see a lot more of
them in future episodes they tease this
really interesting relationship
developing between Bruce Wayne and
Selina Kyle so I'm interested to see
what the show does with that generally I
think what the episode does best is show
that Gotham is a really interesting
place even when Batman is not there like
it doesn't linger on the fact that we
don't see a fully actualized Batman it
doesn't try to be too self-aware so you
don't walk away feeling like something's
missing I'll say one thing that does
have me worried is that the episode
makes a lot of promises that it might
not ever fully be able to deliver on Fox
has paid for the rights to pretty much
every Batman villain with the exception
of the Joker I think that they're able
to use the Joker but not in the way that
the Batman movies use the Joker there
are a lot of fun Batman villain gags
during the episode so you can look
forward to that though as of right now
Fox already ordered 16 episodes there in
the middle of shooting all those they
still have a lot of shooting left to do
so we will see all of season 1 like we
don't have to worry about the show
getting canceled as I start doing videos
for each of the episodes I'll be sure to
include stuff from behind the scenes as
they continue to finish filming just in
general you can expect several more big
Batman villains to show up before the
finale
so be sure to subscribe to get all my
videos it's gonna be a lot of fun I'll
be posting my episode videos about three
to four hours after episodes air on
Monday nights we won't really find out
about season 2 until after the first
several episodes so totally do not worry
about that yet I will be doing videos
all season I was really happy I stuck
with agents of shield last year I know a
lot of people dumped it after the first
couple episodes because they thought it
wasn't that good it really picked up in
the second half of the season so I'm
actually really excited for that show to
come back to and I'm working on the
season 2 preview video for tonight for
that so what's gonna happen next week
whenever that first episode airs is all
live tweet during there are links for
social in the description if you want to
play along with me it's a lot of fun and
then I'll post like a top 10 video after
it's done right now you can click here
to learn more about some of the Batman
villains coming to season 1 and you can
click here to start getting ready for
arrow in the flash thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight high
fives
you